[Musique] les
gens pensent que c'est censé être ce
qu'une fille aux yeux bleus aux cheveux blonds de six pieds de haut
avec de gros vieux
implants qui ressemble à la travailleuse du sexe la plus prospère d'
Amérique,
ils ne s'attendent pas à ce que des images mangent une
rousse comme ça ce n'est pas  l'image
que tout le monde a
[Musique]
je m'appelle alice little
je suis la travailleuse du sexe légale la plus
prospère aux États-Unis
[Musique]
avant la fermeture tant convoitée j'avais
réservé 1,2 million ce qui était
impressionnant
mais
cela en dit plus
sur le fait que  c'est une
carrière
valable  de tailles et de formes et vous
voulez être à l'aise pour vous adapter aux
autres personnes, donc pour moi,
avoir cette capacité à se déplacer,
ouais, je
dois garder les choses en mouvement
lorsque vous êtes à l'aise dans la peau dans laquelle
vous êtes et que vous pouvez ensuite aider
les autres  les ers se sentent à l'aise dans la peau dans laquelle
ils sont vous êtes-vous toujours senti à l'
aise dans votre peau oh non oh
mon dieu maintenant tu te moques de moi comme
tout le monde c'est un voyage surtout
pour les jeunes femmes là-bas comme
ce voyage est
profond pouvoir me voir  dans les cheveux et le
maquillage et ces belles robes et
voir ces images et être comme oh mon dieu
c'est moi merde sainte es-tu sérieux
ça m'a permis de me voir sous un jour
complètement différent et d'avoir cette
nouvelle appréciation de moi-même
hey jason hey richard oh my gosh
bonjour brandon bonjour bonjour
je suis tellement excitée de vous voir tous les bienvenus
allons-y et commençons cette semaine
avec nos
annonces spéciales
salut
je suis au chicken ranch venez me voir
j'aimerais absolument passer du temps
avec vous tous et  eh bien, j'ai vraiment
hâte de voir certains d'entre
vous et de
faire d'autres choses avec certains d'entre vous, mais
bon, nous allons le garder pg-13 afin que
youtube ne me vire pas de la bonne équipe
thé  d'
accord, voyons quelles autres questions
nous avons ici euh jared ai-je fait une
nuit ou est-ce que je fais des nuits avec des
invités ayant des besoins spéciaux absolument oui
j'ai passé des nuits avec des invités des
gens qui utilisent des fauteuils roulants toutes sortes de
choses différentes quelles autres questions nous
avons  ici oui malheureusement mon chat luna
n'a pas pu venir avec moi au bordel
j'aimerais que stephen nous devions
nous débarrasser de cette virginité toi
et moi et artie casey oui je suis toujours disponible
sur rendez-vous uniquement parce que j'ai tellement
de demandes je  je veux m'assurer que
je suis capable d'espacer les choses pour que
tout le monde reçoive une attention personnalisée
je veux vous voir si vous voulez me voir
spécifiquement
je ne sais pas je pense juste qu'il y a
quelque chose de vraiment sympa là
J'ai du temps
pour cette semaine mwah
bye désolé mais je dois
courir ici parce que j'ai en fait un
invité qui regarde probablement le
live qui m'attend et les parkings donc
je vais faire nettoyer ma chambre  p et
ensuite allez passer du temps avec eux ensuite,
alors que savez-vous de vos invités
pour cet après-midi,
donc mon invité pour cet après-midi est en quelque sorte à la
recherche de l'
expérience de la petite amie, il a en quelque sorte décrit
quelque chose d'un peu plus détendu et
beaucoup plus décontracté  de baisers et de câlins
j'aime la petite amie éprouver l'
émotion la chaleur toute cette
belle connectivité que
j'apprécie le plus dans ce travail
il est illégal pour nous de citer des taux exacts en
dollars par heure les taux
commencent généralement dans la fourchette à quatre chiffres et vont
tous les  à partir de là, les invités
qui passent un week-end peuvent facilement dépenser
dans la fourchette à six chiffres de
l'année civile précédente où j'ai travaillé, j'ai
réservé 1,2 million de dollars ouais wow
c'est beaucoup
si bien, c'est certainement un nombre substantiel
cinquante pour cent de cela va automatiquement
au ranch et ensuite 30 de cela va
au gouvernement
donc
c'est le salon
ici c'est le bureau de notre médecin en
tant que travailleur du sexe légal je suis tenu par la loi
de faire  un test std ou sti tous les sept
jours et faire du sang une fois par mois
, puis derrière ici, nous avons aussi une
petite station de danse avec des lumières qui
peuvent être allumées et une traction amusante pour les
femmes qui
ont du talent et savent
danser  Je ne suis pas une de ces dames
[Musique]
tu es sexy
sur le très très peu probable que
si les bordels ferment
nous n'irons nulle part
Elko n'avait rien à propos des pistes de bowling
[Musique]
eh bien non non voici la chose étrange que nous
ne pouvions pas  aller au bateau,
nous pourrions aller dans les casinos bien que dans le
comté d'elko afin que nous puissions aller dans les
casinos mais pas les pistes de bowling dans le
comté d'elko soyons très clairs sur
ce
bowling est mauvais le jeu est bon ouais
seulement si vous êtes un wapiti
et  ça craint parce que même quand nous
faisons les choses, les citations ne sont pas justes de
manière légale, d'une manière propre, nous sommes testés en
payant nos impôts, nous sommes toujours traités de
la même manière
euh six applications maintenant
donc
et  vous gagnez bien au-dessus du
revenu moyen, je veux
dire près de cent mille
par an
et c'est travailler à temps partiel parce que
j'ai un enfant, donc je travaillais une ou deux
semaines par mois peut-être et voir
si cela me donnerait un endroit où vivre je
Je ne suis plus une victime, je suis une survivante maintenant,
mais c'est juste le système qu'ils punissent les
victimes qu'ils marginalisent et
stigmatisent et comme mon histoire, vous savez que j'étais en
fait victime de trafic sexuel par mon meilleur
ami mentalement, je n'étais plus là
comme  je devais aller chercher de l'aide je devais être
admis que j'avais eu tellement de
tentatives de suicide parce que j'aime juste que ça fait mal
d'avoir quelqu'un avec qui
tu as grandi pour te vendre
donc j'ai même de la chance d'être assis ici en
ce moment ouais je le ferais  dis oui mais euh
cette industrie m'a sauvé comme moi de venir dans
les bordels,
les femmes m'ont aidé à
comprendre que je suis en fait une personne dans
la vie qui compte si ce n'était pas pour
les filles qui viennent ici parce qu'elles en ont
besoin un  D'une manière ou d'une autre, j'ai gagné en
stabilité dans ma vie parce que  se de travailler
dans des bordels
est-ce un système parfait absolument pas
peut-il être amélioré absolument oui
mais est-ce mieux que d'être
criminalisé mieux que d'être arrêté et jeté
en prison et traité comme un animal et un
criminel
ouais
littéralement juste entrer dans les bordels
ayant  un certain type de connexion avec
quelqu'un m'a aidé
et
m'aide à aider mes clients
m'aide aussi, c'est pourquoi une autre
raison pour laquelle je pense que le travail du sexe est nécessaire comme
qu'en est-il de la guérison oui oh [ __ ] de guérison et
des pauvres gars c'est comme cinq
ou dix minutes de sexe et  le reste
du temps, ils veulent juste leur
parler de leur vie et ouais
du divorce qu'ils traversent ou de
quelque chose qui se passe avec leur entreprise
ou leur enfant ou quelle que soit la situation
peut-être que j'ai littéralement vu un gars juste plus tôt
cette semaine il était  agressé par un autre
homme quand il était plus jeune et donc comme s'il
avait cette peur de la masculinité
depuis et c'était comme s'il était en larmes à
la fin comme dang
je veux dire toi n  savez jamais quels effets
vous pouvez avoir sur les gens, il ne s'agit pas toujours
uniquement du vieil homme sale qui
veut venir vous pilonner et ne
vous quitte pas car il ne fait
que de mauvaises lois exactement amen amen
bravo à ce droit
[Musique]
quels sont certains des fétiches les plus
courants avec lesquels les gens viennent vous voir
oh il y a tellement de bas en nylon
fétichisme des pieds fétichisme des cheveux
ayant spécifiquement un fétiche rousse
fétiche court j'ai eu quelqu'un avec un
fétiche court et grand me demande et un
très grand co-  travailleur
fétiche à talons hauts lingerie fétiche fétichisme des mains
massage fétiche
euh
donc je suis assez ouvert d'esprit quand il s'agit
de kink et de fétichisme mais éclabousse l'acte
de
prendre de la sauce au chocolat ou de la crème fouettée
et de le mettre sur mon corps et puis comme le
lécher
non merci
je n'utiliserai pas d'insultes contre quelqu'un même
s'ils me le demandent je ne le suis pas
je ne suis pas à l'aise avec ça euh je
n'ai pas non plus de relations sexuelles avec des nazis
cela semble fou mais j'ai eu un nazi
m'a envoyé un email  comme in out et fier
nazi et  j'étais comme euh
non
euh non
comme je ne sais pas comment tu as eu cette
impression mais euh
non
non je ne sais absolument pas
donc je suis tellement capable de décliner des
choses dans ce sens
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment eu de la chance de  grandir sans
honte et sans stigmatisation
ni stigmatisation sexuelle stigmatisation religieuse j'ai
vraiment eu une enfance ouverte dans
le sens où si je voulais apprendre
quelque chose cette
connaissance m'était accessible je savais tout de suite d'où
venaient les bébés et que l'
histoire historique  était une connerie complète
et ce n'était pas quelque chose dont il fallait avoir peur
[Music]
juste pour faire cette carrière comme un acte de
défi contre la
perception de la société de qui vous êtes censé
être
si je veux faire ça, je ne peux pas avoir  toute
honte toute stigmatisation qui y est associée si
j'avais des appréhensions des appréhensions
toute hésitation je prendrais ma retraite aujourd'hui
que j'ai
parlé à thi  s semaine et donc je
vais lui passer un petit coup de fil avant d'aller au lit
bonjour hé comment tu vas
bien
je vais bien aussi comment était ta journée
aujourd'hui
oui comment c'était de retourner au
bureau
ça ne marche pas pour tout le monde  j'ai fait beaucoup
plus de travail à la maison que je ne l'ai jamais fait en
allant dans un bureau
ii je ne savais pas comment je me sentirais en
revenant au travail après avoir été loin d'un
bordel après 14 mois mais comme
vous le savez, ça fait vraiment du bien d'être de retour
et je  j'aime vraiment l'espace nièce aussi
j'imagine que c'est assez agréable de toucher à
nouveau les gens oh tu sais ce que tu sais
ce que j'ai raté
mais de toute façon toi
je vais te laisser partir
je te rejoins demain nous resterons en
contact je  j'espère que tu dors bien
et
ouais toutes les bonnes choses
c'est bon de te parler aussi bonne nuit au
revoir
c'est juste un gars si gentil l'
as-tu rencontré en personne
oh ouais nous avons passé du temps
ensemble avant la pandémie et ensuite
pendant kobe nous  'ai fait quelques appels vidéo
et certains appels téléphoniques avez-vous déjà été
attaché à des gens, c'est qu'un  n problème pour
vous est que ce n'est pas un problème pour vous en
fait
peut-être que c'est un peu un problème pour
moi dans le sens où j'aime vraiment
me soucier des
gens beaucoup de mes invités sont plus âgés et beaucoup
d'entre eux ont des problèmes médicaux
vous  sais que nous avons traversé une pandémie et
je mentirais si je disais que tous mes
clients ont fait en sorte que cela
ne soit pas du tout affecté tu sais
que j'ai eu un invité qui m'a dit que tu sais
hé tu sais
à l'hôpital
et j'ai découvert plus tard que cette personne était
décédée et
wow, je m'étouffe ici,
donc je veux dire
bien sûr que je m'en soucie, mais je ne peux pas dire que
c'est un problème qui m'importe,
mais
comment pouvez-vous être humain  et je ne me soucie pas de
la vie d'un autre humain
et je ne pense pas que ce soit unique à
ma profession, tu sais que je me soucie d'eux,
je ne veux que le meilleur pour eux
et entendre que quelqu'un est décédé
d'
une pandémie est horrible comme ça, tu sais
que c'est déchirant
je donne beaucoup de temps à cette carrière
dans cette profession c'est quelque chose  hing que
je prends très au sérieux et donc je
travaille dieu
80 semaines de travail de 90 heures tout le temps, donc je
veux dire que je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps en dehors
de mon travail pour une autre personne dans une relation entière
comme
quand je ne travaille pas je  je m'occupe de
mes animaux de compagnie je suis dans le jardin je m'entraîne
je fais des randonnées je
voyage je fais tellement de
choses différentes qui apportent tellement de satisfaction à
ma vie
tu sais je me sens très bien  t'aimais
[Musique]